vielleicht können sie das einmal sagen
was ist mittlerweile denn über diese
langzeitfolgen wirklich bekannt ja guten
abend es ist noch etwas früh vielleicht
viel über die langzeitwirkung zu sagen
weil das die krankheit kennen wir erst
weniger als ein jahr dennoch wissen wir
dass es einige langzeitwirkungen
wahrscheinlich geben wird zum beispiel
was den rief nerv angeht haben wir
gelernt das ist ja ein sehr frühes eine
sehr frühe ist zeigen auch das einzige
zeichen ist und selbst die akute
erkrankung schon vorbei ist dauert es
dennoch einige wochen bevor sich der
riesenhaften erholen kann aber wir haben
auch zum beispiel bei patienten die
beatmet werden mussten auch lungen
schädigungen also die patienten sind
dann noch sehr schnell müde erschöpft
kurzatmig und sind auch nach wochen
nachdem jack und erkrankung vorbei ist
noch nicht in der leistungsfähigkeit wie
sie vorher einmal daran hätte ich meinen
geruchssinn sie haben gerade
angesprochen dass es etwas von dem wir
alle schon viel gehört haben aber kann
man auch schon absehen was vor allem mit
der lunge passiert diese ist ja im von
corona meisten betroffenen inwiefern
weiß man schon ob das sich auf jahre
dann abzeichnet ja auch jahre das kann
man tatsächlich noch nicht an die gute
nachricht ist wir haben jetzt gerade
erste untersuchung gemacht bei patienten
die nicht bearbeitet werden mussten
dort haben wir keine langzeitfolgen und
lungenschädigung feststellen können
allerdings sehr viel müdigkeit und
abgeschlagenheit und eben
unkonzentriertheit bei patienten die die
warten mussten da sehen wir doch
deutliche funktionseinschränkungen der
lunge die zumindest noch monate nach der
akuten erkrankung anhält weil sie sich
auch vorstellen durch diese invasive
beatmung sind natürlich auch tatsächlich
schädigungen des gerüstes dann induziert
durch die beratung und hier kann man
muss man befürchten dass tatsächlich
auch die langzeitwirkung
manchmal sogar irreversibel sind und
eine weitere frage zu den neurologischen
schäden wie sieht es damit aus dem vor
allem wie gefährlich können diese seien
ja immer noch relativ wenig erkenntnisse
wir wissen es gibt natürlich akute dinge
wie schlaganfälle wir haben aber auch
als langzeitwirkungen verwirrtheit
unkonzentriertheit oder auch eine
epilepsie aber gerade was die neurologie
angeht haben wir hier noch nicht sehr
viele harte daten hier müssen das wohl
noch einige monate vielleicht auch etwas
länger gedulden bis wir wirklich
zuverlässige aussagen machen können
mai abschließend lässt sich sagen wer er
von diesen langzeitschäden betroffen ist
sind das eher ältere patienten jüngere
patienten oder ist es am ende der
verlauf der krankheit dafür entscheidend
wie sehen sie das
auch das ist nicht einfach zu
beantworten allerdings ist es schon so
zum beispiel dieser dieses probleme des
riechens das haben auch sehr viele
patienten mit milden verlauf das ist
noch länger dauert die ansonsten kann
man eigentlich sagen wer milden verlauf
hat lange nach nachwirkungen werden
akuten schweren verlauf weniger
nachwirkungen
zumindest was die lungenschädigung
angeht gehe ich davon aus dass zumindest
die patienten mehr betroffen sind die
wirklich von uns viele tage und manche
ja auch wochen invasiv und was ich
beatmet werden müssen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren